hey this is P peppers with candy crush
soda saga tips com and this is a
walkthrough with commentary for candy
crush soda level 185 this is a tough
level people have been having trouble
with it for a long time so I thought I
would talk about some of the tips as I
go through and beat it in the beginning
you can see I'm just trying to set up
some stripes that go down to make some
damage and clear not some space and we
want to plan how we're going to use our
bottoms like we should be able to make
some bombs because of the colors that
are involved and we don't really want to
use them especially right now and
there's no candies at the bottom we're
all use them by themselves so we'll make
combos like this and it's real important
especially as the level progresses to
take your time like here you can see
with two matches we can drop that orange
one down to make a suckered color bomb
and if everything stays in place we can
match the red below and match the two
color bombs together so you definitely
want to be thinking about that and here
we go it only takes one layer off but it
also creates a big cascade and hopefully
we'll get some more hits and now we just
want to repeat that process the holes in
the middle make it really hard you know
pieces aren't going to once the top
bears are gone it's going to they're
just going to make it look a little
bottle neck so that we can't you know
directly hit the but the Bears below so
we're looking for now here okay so we
see we have most of it will try to set
up another bomb and that worked out so
you want to look for those gaps and here
we have another spot and there you go so
you just want to you want before you
start you know making making your
matches you want to try to see if you
have any chance instead of color but it
doesn't work every time obviously but
now we have a pretty good amount of
airs taken off of the entire board and
we have 26 moves left so we're not out
of the woods yet you'd like to think if
you make a couple big colorbar matches
that it would just work out but it's not
necessarily the case so here I have
these vertical blues and I'm going to
see if I can drop another blue in to
make a bomb there go ahead and make this
striped and drop the greens that way I
think maybe make the top stripe too I
don't know that might have been a little
bit of a waste of because there there's
no bears at the top so let's see we
didn't really get a blue to drop down I
think the stripes with the fish is a
good match because it will take out
hopefully the bottom row and it didn't
but that's okay just want to take some
yeah I think here we'll just hit this
because that will give us a little more
space that way if we can make like a
bomb of the with a striped or fish you
know that will be more effective at this
point the stripes the vertical stripes
aren't that important anymore
horizontals can be good if we let's see
if we can make a bomb here the
horizontal stripes can definitely get if
we match them with the fish
okay so that we get dropping the orange
again and just try to set up the combo
I'd like to get I think maybe like a
wrapped plus the color bomb would be the
best right now because we might better
get a couple to drop in there really
damage the bottom and you can see how
this is like here we can set up a raft
here move the red up match it and
that'll put the yeah I think this will
be a good one um there's only two orange
at the bottom but we have eight moves
and I think that would clear out some
serious face so I think that's the way
we want to go
and there aren't there aren't bears and
all of them we can see two and there's
one more believe it yeah it's over here
on the left side where the you can see
the blue candy out its behind that there
it's next to the blue candy that you can
sort of see so we get six minutes is
pretty good just have to make a couple
fish or use some some other specials to
hit it now it just needs one more see we
there's a couple things we could do here
we go ahead and fire this off because
it's not going to mess up the match at
the bottom and there we go so it's
really frustrating level don't get me
wrong but if you plan things out you can
do it you know the regular specials
really won't do it by themselves you
really have to look for bombs and combos
and take your time and look for those
gaps because if you can set those up
that's going to make a big difference I
hope this helps please like the video
share it subscribe to our channel
because we make new videos like this all
the time and we need your support and
i'll be making more soon so talk to you
later